speaking of your amazing cast kristen
stewart you know i've been such a big
fan of hers ever since panic room you
know that was the first film i saw her
in i've been following her career what
was it like working with her well i just
want to say there's one strange thing
she has a movie out called spencer
in which her character is named spencer
and my name in slasher is spencer that's
true yes
it's my first name yeah yeah so i
thought okay this is sort of some kind
of kismet you know that we should be
working together
she's fantastic she's
she really is a truly wonderful actress
and i i had no idea quite how brilliant
she was until i was directing her which
is often the case
and we were very lucky to get her very
excited to get her and and she's
fantastic i mean she has a scene with
viggo that will knock your socks off
believe me
um yeah so it's it and we have leia sedu
uh who's at the moment i think probably
france's favorite actress and who is
coming out in uh in the new james bond
film she's in that film so it's really
very exciting and you know
and uh um
as they say a wonderful cast and
fantastic location and so if it's no
good it's my fault
i take full responsibility
i love that um speaking of spencer have
you seen the film yet
with spencer yeah have you seen kristen
stewart in that film yet i have seen it
it's
yeah i have seen it because uh just
yesterday i did an hour conversation
with her of course for a publication
called document journal
and uh so we got to talk
after not seeing each other since she
left this you know the the production
uh and that was really lovely to do it
was really great and uh
so in anticipation of that they asked me
if i would like to see
spencer
yeah and so i got a link to a secure
site of course
and i watched it and she's she really is
terrific it's a really beautiful
beautifully nuanced performance
oh man that is so exciting i yeah i
cannot cannot wait for that um this is a
silly question
however you want to answer this this is
just for the twilight fans out there
obviously you've worked with barbara
pattinson kristen stewart now would you
love to direct them both of themselves
um
if if the if if the casting were right i
mean the first time i met kristen was on
the set of cosmopolis in toronto and she
was visiting the set because at that
time she was rob's girlfriend yeah
[Music]
and
so it was you know
but it always really depends on the
chemistry what their relationship is
with each other i have no idea i really
don't but i do know
that from coming from twilight which
you would never say was known for its
great acting
uh they've both developed into really
phenomenal performers both of them and
that's pretty great i mean i i saw that
with rob right away that's why i wanted
for cosmopolis
and to get kristen well it's a lovely
little circle you know complete the
circle it's really very sweet